[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
in allen je später der Abend desto
explosiver die Themen das gilt auf jeden
Fall für den Parteitag der Grünen der
nach drei Jahren wieder in Vollbesetzung
stattfindet was für eine grüne
Parteiführung ja schon traditionell das
Risiko steigen lässt so richtig
überrascht zu werden jetzt im Moment in
einer Halle in Bonn kommt noch dazu die
Partei Basis muss einiges mitmachen an
realpolitischen kehrtwänden Waffen in
ein Kriegsgebiet Milliarden für die
Rüstung Kohlekraftwerke die länger
laufen und dann auch noch ein
Atomausstieg der wackeln könnte das wird
ein spannender Abend und man tritt der
Parteitagsregie wohl nicht zu nahe wenn
man annimmt dass die schwierigsten
Debatten mit einiger Absicht in den
späten Abend gelegt wurden Andreas
Huppert
wenn Umweltschützer klimaaktivisten und
die Antiatomkraftbewegung gegen die
Grünen demonstrieren dann ist der
politische Kompass in Unordnung geraten
dann stimmt da etwas nicht
unsere klare Message hier an den
Bundesparteitag auch nicht übers Ziel
hinausschießen eine klare pragmatische
Linie fahren ohne Verlängerung von
Atomkraft ohne die Nutzung von
Braunkohle ja die Grünen Parteispitze
bettelt ja im Moment geradezu um einen
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke sie
lässt sich von der FDP treiben völlig
ohne Fakten ich bin aber ausgetreten bei
den Grünen ich bin jetzt bei der Klima
Liste in hoffe mir dass die Grünen auch
von der Seite ein bisschen Druck
bekommen noch mehr Druck also für den
Bonner Parteitag auf dem die Grünen
darüber abstimmen wie Deutschland
möglichst unbeschadet durch diese
energiepolitisch aus den Fugen geratene
Welt zu steuern ist
die fossilen Energien und die Atomkraft
sie haben uns diese energienot beschert
sie sind nicht die Lösung sie sind das
Problem die Menschen trotzdem müssen
ausgerechnet die Grünen jetzt mittragen
das Atomkraftwerke länger laufen das mit
Kohle weiter Strom erzeugt wird das Gas
ins Land kommt möglichst billig dafür
braucht habe die Unterstützung der
Partei willkommen in der schönen neuen
grünen Wirklichkeit ganz ehrlich Politik
gute Politik die macht man für die
Realität die da ist und nicht für die
Realität die man sich gewünscht hat
dabei geht es um nicht weniger als um
die DNA der Partei um die Wurzeln um die
Grundsätze gegründet von Atomkraft
Gegnern entstanden aus der
Friedensbewegung immer unterstützt von
Klimaschützern wir haben beantragt dass
wir unsere Klimaziele fest in den Blick
nehmen müssen und von daher bin ich sehr
gespannt auf diese Button von Parteitag
und hoffe mir ein deutliches Zeichen
dass wir solidarisch an der Seite der
Klimabewegung stehen vor allem das Thema
Atomkraft spaltet zwei Meiler sollen
länger laufen streckbetrieb ist das
Zauberwort bis April so will es die
Parteispitze ein Gegenantrag von der
Partei Basis fordert am Jahresende
abzuschalten
den Anfang des langen deutschen
Ausstiegs aus der Atomkraft hat er
damalige Umweltminister Jürgen Trittin
verhandelt guten Abend Herr Trittin
guten Abend der Sievers wird denn der
Parteitag jetzt zustimmen dass eben doch
nicht Schluss ist Ende des Jahres
sondern zwei Atomkraftwerke erstmal in
Reserve bleiben
ich vermute dass der Parteitag
beschließt dass bis zum 15.4 nächsten
Jahres zwei Kraftwerke im Süden in
Bayern und in Baden-Württemberg in einer
Reservebetrieb gehalten werden danach so
die Vereinbarung mit den Betreibern
beginnt der Rückbau was soll denn dann
Mitte April eigentlich anders sein das
Thema Energieknappheit Stromprobleme das
bleibt doch auch im April noch
ja und deswegen ist es ja so gut dass
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck einen
Stresstest in Auftrag gegeben hat der
hat festgestellt dass wir in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland als solche
keine strommangelage haben wir haben
sogar einen Gebieten Nord- und
Nordostdeutschlands stromüberschüsse die
bis heute dazu führen dass wir
Windkraftparks abschalten müssen aber
wir haben bedingt durch ein
Zusammenwirken sehr schwieriger Faktoren
nämlich dem Desaster der Turm Energie in
Frankreich wo die Hälfte der Anlagen
steht
Lehrer Speicher sehen und auch des
Umstandes des Kohlekraftwerke die wir
gerne ans Netz gebracht hätten nicht
gerne aber ans Netz bringen wollten
nicht ans Netz gebracht werden können
weil Kohle wegen zu niedriger
Wasserstände in den Flüssen nicht
transportiert werden kann dass wir dort
ein Bedarf an Regelenergie haben und zu
dieser Regel Energie kann die
Atomenergie ein klein aber auch nur
einen kleinen Beitrag machen diese
Bedingung werden im Frühjahr dann andere
sein Patrick den sie wissen die FDP also
ihr Koalitionspartner in Berlin sieht
das anders und Minister Habeck muss mit
dem Finanzminister und dem Bundeskanzler
jetzt schnell irgendein Kompromiss
finden was ist denn wenn bei diesem
Kompromiss dann mehr Kernkraft
herauskommt als sie heute auf ein
Parteitag beschließen
es gibt einen Kompromiss das ist das
Angebot was wir machen ansonsten bleibt
es bei der Rechtslage die die FDP an der
Bundesregierung nach Fukushima
mitgeschaffen hat nämlich dem Ende der
Atomenergie am 31.12 aber das ist ja
kein Kompromiss wenn sie sagen es bleibt
entweder bei unserem Angebot oder es
passiert gar nichts die Frage ist doch
wie viel Spielraum ja aber die konkrete
Frage ist ja wie viel Spielraum hat der
Minister Habeck für Kompromisse nach
diesem Parteitag noch sprich muss er
sich an diesen Parteitagsbeschluss bis
zum letzten Komma und Punkt halten oder
hat der Kompromiss Möglichkeiten und
noch so ein bisschen Raum für sich
selbst in der in der Bundesregierung
der Kompromiss sieht vor dass zum 15.4
der Reservebetrieb endet er schreibt
klar fest dass wir keine neuen
Brennelemente kaufen das hat auch eine
Ursache weil wir wollen nicht
zusätzlichen Atommüll Produzieren von
dem wir nicht wissen wo er hin muss und
erhält fest an dem was übrigens mit dem
Betreibern der Atomkraftwerke vereinbart
worden ist nämlich dass sie sich bereit
finden gegen Geld im übrigen diesen
Reservebetrieb zu machen aber dann aus
dieser Technologie wirklich aussteigen
wollen weil das auch ihre Neuaufstellung
als
Energieunternehmen in einer Weise
beschädigt die nicht in Ihrem Interesse
ist aber ich muss doch noch mal auf die
Verhandlungen in der Regierung die ja
sehr wichtig sind für Deutschland
hinaus bei der ganzen Geschichte und bei
der Frage wie viel Verhandlungsspielraum
Robert Habeck denn noch hat nach diesem
Parteitag also legt ihn der Parteitag
jetzt an die Kette
dieser Parteitag fasst ein Beschluss mit
einem Angebot an die FDP wenn dieses
Angebot nicht gewünscht ist ja dann ist
das was in Koalitionsvertrag drin steht
nämlich das Ende der Atomenergie 2012
auf der Basis des Gesetzes dass die FDP
selber gemacht hat die Alternative ich
kann dazu nicht raten weil ich glaube
selbst wenn man die Rolle der
Atomenergie bei der Versorgung
Sicherheit nicht besonders hoch
einschätzt das ist das Ergebnis des
Stresstestes dann ist es trotzdem
vielleicht eine psychologische
Beruhigung neben Gürtel und Hosenträgern
nach einem zweites Paar Hosenträger im
Schrank zu hängen das ist das Angebot
was wir machen gut das werden dann das
kann man dazu voraussehen keine
einfachen Verhandlungen werden in der
Bundesregierung Herr Trittin manche
sagen auch dieser Mini Reservebetrieb
der reicht einfach nicht was sagen sie
denn zu der Argumentation dass uns auf
der einen Seite uns Bürgerinnen und
Bürger der Staat sagt sparen sparen
sparen und auf der anderen Seite der
Staat dann aber nicht alle Kleinigkeiten
der Energieerzeugung auch wirklich nutzt
ja deshalb diese Antwort finden Sie im
Stresstest zum Beispiel stellt der
Stress des fest dass der Weiterbetrieb
von Atomanlagen kein Gas spart das
gaseinsparpotenzial wird dort mit einem
Promille veranschlagt das ist die
Realität und ich finde wenn man solche
stressset macht dann muss man auch mit
den Ergebnissen entsprechend umgehen
sagt Jürgen Trittin ich danke Ihnen für
das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
die Debatte läuft noch das Gespräch
haben wir ganz kurz vor dieser Sendung
aufgezeichnet
es muss etwas geschehen da sind sich die
EU Innenminister heute einig sie meinen
die zunehmende Zahl von Flüchtlingen die
nach Europa kommen wir Balkan die
Situation ist zwar nicht vergleichbar
mit der 2015 aber die EU hat in diesem
Jahr zusätzlich insgesamt 4,2 Millionen
Menschen aus der Ukraine aufgenommen für
die auch gesorgt werden muss und deshalb
Gerät jetzt insbesondere Serbien ins
Visier von Europas Grenzschützern das
Land will einerseits EU-Mitglied werden
und sorgt andererseits mit einer ganz
speziellen Visapolitik in Brüssel
verärgert Britta Hilpert hat sich die
Lage vor Ort auf der Balkanroute
angesehen
sie kommen meist auf dem Landweg viele
kommen aus Krieg und Elend und Elend
begleitet sie bis hier im serbischen
Niemandsland und weit der Grenze warten
sie auf die Nacht auf ihre Chance den
ungarischen Grenzzaun zu überwinden
immer wieder versuchen Sie es an Zurück
gibt es nicht winter is coming der
Winter kommt es wird kalt und ich kann
da nicht draußen schlafen ich kann nicht
in eine feste Unterkunft weiter weg ich
muss an der Grenze bleiben ich will
rüber
auch sie wollen rüber seit August dürfen
Inder visafrei nach Serbien einreisen
weil Indien im Kosovo Konflikt auf
Serbien Seite steht die in der Nutzen
Serbien als Sprungbrett in die EU
die eu-innenministerinnen ärgert dass
Serbien ihr Migrationsproblem vergrößert
die Visa praxisorientiert sich daran
welche Staaten den Kosovo nicht
anerkennen das finde ich auch nicht
akzeptabel und Serbien muss seine
visapraxis an die EU anpassen serbien
will Mal Mitglied werden in dieser Runde
die heute einig ist in ihrer Kritik am
Beitrittskandidaten und das lenkt ab vom
Kern des Problems ihrer Uneinigkeit in
der Migrationspolitik denn auf der
Balkanroute sind gerade mal 4.500 Inder
von
106.000 geflüchteten in diesem Jahr und
jedes Land entlang der Route will vor
allem sein eigenes Migrationsproblem
lösen
Österreich zum Beispiel hat 213 Prozent
mehr asylanträger als im Vorjahr aber
nur ein Bruchteil der Antragsteller
bleibt im Land man lässt sie ziehen
dennoch hier sind Unterkünfte knapp man
fördert das sogar die Regierung verteilt
solche Bahntickets ins Inland nach
Westen erzählte ein flüchtlingshelfer er
vermutet System weil sie nun quasi auch
Menschen weiterschickt mit der ins
geheimen Hoffnung dass die Menschen auch
in andere EU-Länder weiterfahren was
auch tatsächlich der Fall ist viele
wollen nach Belgien Frankreich Italien
oder Deutschland aber Geschichten wie
die von John sheet aus Afghanistan
erzählen auch davon dass die EU nicht
nur uneins ist sie greift in der
Migrationspolitik auch zu kurz
wir sind hier weil Krieg ist in
Afghanistan die Situation dort ist
schlecht wir sind nach Europa gekommen
damit Europa uns hilft bis wir wieder
zurück können
sie können nicht zurück und die EU kommt
nicht voran in der Migrationspolitik
Europa wird sich einstellen müssen auf
mehr geflüchtete
und Hanna du guckst jetzt in
Deutschlands Innenstädte ganz genau
Christian denn in Deutschlands letzte
große Warenhauskette Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof hat erneut einen Antrag auf
Staatshilfe gestellt das wurde der
Deutschen Presseagentur aus
Regierungskreisen bestätigt hintergrund
sind die explodierenden Energiekosten
und die gesunkene Kauflaune aufgrund der
hohen Inflation schon 2021 und Anfang
2022 hatte das Unternehmen staatliche
Unterstützung aufgrund der
corona-pandemie beantragt damals bekam
der Konzern insgesamt 680 Millionen Euro
zu Höhe der diesmal beantragten Hilfen
gibt es bisher keine Informationen
der Bundestag hat über den von
Bundesregierung geplanten 200 Milliarden
Euro schweren abwehr-schirmen gegen die
Energiekrise debattiert der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion Mittelberg begrüßte zwar
die geplante gaspreisbremse erklärte
allerdings dass diese zu spät komme zu
dem sei bisher unklar wofür das Geld
genau ausgegeben werden solle die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linken Lötsch kritisierte das reiche
Menschen mehr Geld erhielten als ärmere
Menschen der afd-abgeordnete Böhringer
sprach von einem Blankoscheck
nach dem massiven Raketenbeschuss auf
ukrainische Städte zu Beginn der Woche
erklärte russlands Präsident Putin heute
dass er aktuell keine Notwendigkeit für
weitere großflächige Angriffe sehe
stattdessen kündigte er den gezielten
Beschuss von Objekten an die nicht wie
geplant getroffen wurden zum Abschluss
einer Konferenz mit Verbündeten im
kasachischen Astana sagte Putin außerdem
dass die Teilmobilmachung in zwei Wochen
abgeschlossen sei nach seiner
Darstellung wurden von 300.000 Rekruten
mehr als
220.000 einberufen
im Prozess um den Mordanschlag auf die
maltesische Journalistin Daphne Caruana
Galizia sind zwei Brüder wegen Mordes
schuldig gesprochen worden eine
Richterin verurteilte sie zu je 40
Jahren Haft nachdem sie heute zum
Prozess Auftakt überraschend gestanden
hatten die Journalistin 2017 mit einer
Autobombe getötet zu haben Caruana
Galizia war eine der bekanntesten
JournalistInnen Maltas und berichtete
über Korruption Geldwäsche und andere
illegale Geschäfte
bei einer schweren Explosion in einem
Kohlebergwerk im Norden der Türkei sind
nach Angaben des Innenministers
mindestens 14 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen weitere 28 sein verletzt bis zu
50 Menschen könnten sich in der Mine
eingeschlossen sein hunderte Meter unter
der Erde die Ursache des Unglücks ist
noch unklar
in Schweden steht nach der
Parlamentswahl im September ein
Regierungswechsel bevor drei Parteien
des rechten Lagers einigten sich auf
eine Minderheitsregierung die erstmals
von den rechtspopulistischen Schweden
Demokraten im Parlament unterstützt wird
die vier Parteien kündigten ein härteres
Vorgehen in den Bereichen Kriminalität
und Einwanderung an zudem sollen neue
Atomreaktoren gebaut werden der Chef der
konservativen christason soll am Montag
zumindest der Präsidenten gewählt werden
die covid-pandemie kommt zurück warnt
der Bundesgesundheitsminister heute was
auch zurückkommt ist das ungute Gefühl
dass sich die Diskussion dazu bei uns
zunehmend im Kreis dreht und dieses Land
im Corona Jahr 3 immer noch mit
fehlenden Daten kämpft und einem
Gesundheitssystem in dem der Mangel
verwaltet wird und zwar ganz unabhängig
von der Pandemie
Karl Lauterbach hat heute jedenfalls
eine neue Kampagne vorgestellt er will
damit aufrütteln und hat gleichzeitig
irritiert Britta Spiekermann und Dominik
Chapka berichten
halten auch Sie Ihren corona-schutz
aktuell zusammen gegen corona.de
Minister Lauterbach und seine
Impfkampagne besser soll sie sein als
alle vorangegangenen rund 33 Millionen
Euro hat sie gekostet Lauterbach
empfiehlt die Impfung für die über
60-Jährigen und für die mit
Vorerkrankungen empfiehlt sie eigentlich
allen auch wenn die Ständige
Impfkommission das gerade nicht tut wir
waren auch viele jüngere erreichen und
also man muss nur schauen welche also
Empfehlungen wir da noch bekommen und
betont dass er den Sitzungen der
Ständigen Impfkommission inzwischen
persönlich beiwohne eigentlich ein
unabhängiges Gremium eigentlich allein
zuständig für Impfempfehlungen ich habe
keinen Einfluss auf die Beschlüsse und
habe auch keinerlei Stimmrecht aber es
ist natürlich wichtig dass der Minister
sich ein Bild auch verschafft über den
Verlauf der Diskussion Lauterbach der
ausdrücklich keine Angst Kampagne
starten will hat heute auf dem Podium
Margarete Stokowski an seiner Seite sie
ist Buchautorin Kolumnistin und
anonkovit erkrankt ich bin hier heute
das abschreckungsbeispiel für longo wird
normalerweise bin ich Autorin bzw ich
war es vorher
meine Infektion war im Januar ich war
dreimal geimpft also ich war ziemlich
frisch gebustert und seitdem bin ich
krank die Botschaft man ist nicht sicher
vor long kovid auch nicht wenn man jung
und geimpft ist solche Fälle sind aber
eher die Ausnahme Lauterbach mahnt die
Länder die maskenpflicht im Innenräumen
zu verhängen man Menschen in Pflegeheim
sich nicht nur viermal sondern bei
Bedarf auch fünfmal impfen zu lassen es
ist jetzt wirklich an der Zeit die
Fallzahlen steigen die Zahl der
Todesfälle mit und an Corona steigt die
Intensivstationen
belegen sich zunehmend und sind in
einigen Bereichen bereits vor der
Überlastung aber im Gegensatz zu den
letzten beiden Jahren ist darunter auch
ein substanzieller Anteil der die
corona-infektion jetzt nicht als
Haupterkrankung hat und das
unterscheidet uns doch ganz gravierend
von den letzten beiden Wintern
ich schütze mich ist der Titel der
Kampagne wer sich impfen lässt gehört
laut Lauterbach dazu das ist auch etwas
wie ein Lagerfeuer und noch einmal die
zusammenkommen die die Pandemie weiter
ernst nehmen und versuchen durch diesen
schweren Herbst oder Winter
durchzukommen das ist ein Lagerfeuer der
vernünftigen während in Europa Masken
und Maßnahmen weitestgehend gefallen
sind macht Lauterbach Druck und ist sich
sicher dass er den einzig richtigen Weg
geht
bis zu drei Jahre Haft für die
Verbreitung von Falschinformationen so
steht das in einem neuen Gesetz dass das
türkische Parlament beschlossen hat
offiziell um damit Desinformation zu
bekämpfen nur was das genau ist und wer
darüber entscheidet bleibt unklar und
damit liegt bereits das große Problem
auf dem Tisch türkische
Journalistenverbände warnen vor einer
neuen Form der Zensur im Land und das
Gesetz betrifft nicht nur die Presse
sondern alle Nutzer etwa von Twitter
oder Facebook aus Istanbul berichtet
Lück wahlport
wenn dieses zensurgesetz durchkommt dann
könnt ihr euer Smartphone auch gleich
zertrümmern so rief dieser empörte
oppositionsabgeordnete den Bürgern zu
bis zuletzt versuchte die Opposition das
Ganze zu stoppen vergeblich
sie wollen vor den Wahlen im nächsten
Jahr die Opposition im Land mundtot
machen darum geht es Ihnen bei diesem
Gesetz
ein bis drei Jahre Haft drohen demnächst
jedem ob Journalist Parteiorganisation
oder Bürger wenn er wie es heißt falsche
oder irreführende Informationen
verbreitet die die öffentliche Ordnung
stören die Sicherheit des Landes
betreffen oder Angst schüren wer
entscheidet was Fake News sind wird
nicht erwähnt für Experten kein Zufall
das Gesetz enthält Begriffe wie Angst
zum Beispiel die sind im türkischen
Recht nirgendwo definiert ebenso fehlt
im Text wer eigentlich festlegt was
irreführende Informationen sind
mit anderen Worten der Willkür wird Tür
und Tor geöffnet für die Journalisten
der linken Tageszeitung birgin ist das
nicht neu aber mit jedem neuen Gesetz
wird die freie Meinungsäußerung weiter
abgewirkt
progress die klassischen Medien haben
sie schon weitgehend auf Linie gebracht
mit Sanktionen Drohungen Strafprozessen
werbeboykott jetzt wollen sie Angst bei
den sozialen Medien schüren und zu
verhindern dass das Ausmaß der Probleme
in Land thematisiert und geteilt wird
seit Monaten laufen Journalisten
Verbände Sturm gegen das Gesetz Erdogan
wegen rekordinflationen Umfrage tief
wolle vor den Wahlen die Presse knebeln
so ihr Vorwurf
die Regierung verbreitet selbst laufend
Falschinformationen wenn wir darauf
hinweisen dass die Inflation nicht 80
sondern real 150% beträgt werden wir
demnächst ins Gefängnis geworfen
wer ist im Besitz der Wahrheit für das
Presseamt des Präsidenten sind die
Fronten jedenfalls klar
diejenigen die sich am heftigsten gegen
dieses Gesetz wären sind die die am
meisten Lügen und falsche Informationen
verbreiten
das Presseamt brandmarkt schon jetzt
wöchentlich Medienberichte die der
Palast als Fake News einstuft
für das was in Großbritannien gerade
passiert braucht man starke Nerven der
Finanzplatz London Symbol für Tradition
und Beständigkeit ist in Aufruhr Hannah
die Regierung mutet dem Land eine
wirklich selten gesehene Achterbahnfahrt
zu ja das kann man so sagen nach weniger
als 40 Tagen im Amt hat der britische
Finanzminister quartang heute seinen Job
verloren Großbritanniens
Premierministerin Trust hat ihn
entlassen und zwar wegen
hochumstrittener Steuersenkungsplänen
die Trust selbst mitverantwortet hatte
neuer Finanzminister soll der frühere
Gesundheits- und Außenminister Jeremy
Hand werden und außerdem verkündete
Trust auch noch eine Kehrtwende in der
Steuerpolitik Frank Bethmann was ist da
genau los in Großbritannien es ist ein
politisches Beben mit starken
finanzwirtschaftlichen Schwingungen um
das zu verstehen muss man begreifen was
dazwischenzeitlich auf dem Spielstand
nicht weniger als die nationale
Altersvorsorge danach Bekanntgabe der
massiven steuersenk inner rauschten die
britischen Staatsanleihen ab offenbar so
stark dass die Bank auf England sofort
mit stützungskäufen reagieren musste
weil sie viel besser als wir wusste wer
hält denn da eigentlich die britischen
Staatsanleihen da sind im großen Stil
die britischen Pensionsfonds um deren
Kollaps zu vermeiden griff die
Zentralbank also entschlossen ein und
nun aber hat deren Chef Andrew Bailey
angekündigt ab heute wäre Schluss damit
nach Ansicht von Experten wollte er
damit genau das erreichen was jetzt
passiert die Regierung knickt ein die
Unternehmenssteuer wird nun doch
angehoben nicht gesenkt damit aber
verzichtet List Trust im Prinzip auf das
Kernstück ihrer Reform nämlich auf das
milliardenschwere steuersenkungspaket
wir haben dann die Finanzmärkte auf die
heutigen Geschehnisse reagiert ja die
Lage bleibt angespannt Investoren
griffen zwar wieder bei den
Staatsanleihen zu im Prinzip ein gutes
Zeichen das von Stirling aber heute
weiter auf Talfahrt Ausdruck des
fehlenden Vertrauens der Finanzmärkte
die britische Wirtschaft schwer
angeschlagen genauso wie ihre
Premierministerin danke Frank für diese
Einschätzung
die Piloten der Lufthansa-Tochter
Eurowings wollen ab kommende Monat 3
Montag drei Tage lang streiken dazu hat
die gewerkschaftsvereinigung Cockpit
aufgerufen nachdem Tarifverhandlungen
mit dem Management des Unternehmens
erneut scheiterten die Gewerkschaft
fordert längere Ruhezeiten und kürzere
Einsätze weil die Pilotinnen und Piloten
überlastet sein die Vergütung des
Cockpitpersonals sei nicht Gegenstand
der Verhandlungen
in der Fußball-Bundesliga sind am Abend
der FC Schalke 04 und die TSG Hoffenheim
aufeinander getroffen vor wenigen
Minuten wurde das Spiel abgepfiffen und
Hoffenheim hat gewonnen entstand 0:3
der Schauspieler Ralf Wolter ist tot er
starb im Alter von 95 Jahren wie seine
Ehefrau mitteilte Wolter wurde vor allem
durch zahlreiche Karl mayverfilmungen
der 60er Jahre bekannt an der Seite von
Winnetou Darsteller Pierre Brice spielte
er insgesamt sechs Mal den Trapper Sam
Hawkins dabei galt volta als
Idealbesetzung dysymatischen
tollpatsches
ausnahmsweise am Ende dieser Sendung
heute das allerwichtigste die Liebe
fünf Buchstaben die uns in den siebten
Himmel tragen und manchmal wahnsinnig
machen über die Liebe ist schon so viel
geschrieben gereimt und gesungen worden
kann man Liebe ausstellen das Haus der
Geschichte in Stuttgart versucht genau
das und kann dabei auf gute Erfahrungen
bauen denn auch die beiden
vorangegangenen Ausstellungen zu Hass
und Gier waren bereits Riesenerfolge
großes Interesse an Gefühlen und
erstaunliche Einsichten wie Liebe
Gesellschaft und Geschichte prägt Petra
Otto und Jasmin astaki Bade haben mehr
[Musik]
ebay muss manchmal viel aushalten auch
Zäune wie den corona-zaun an der
Schweizer Grenze im Frühling 2020 eine
Grenzüberquerung war wochenlang nur mit
einem triftigen Grund möglich Liebe
Zelte nicht dazu
[Musik]
du darfst nicht mehr rüber und jetzt
plötzlich ey jetzt geht da nicht den
Zaun durch man sieht sich nicht mehr
doch liebe durchbricht Schranken weckt
Kräfte und in Stuttgart hat sie es gar
ins Museum geschafft nach Ausstellungen
zu Gier und Hass ist die Liebe krönender
Schlusspunkt einer Trilogie und nicht
nur ein Gefühl zwischen zwei Menschen
die Liebe ist natürlich muss auf dem
ersten Blick die positive Kraft die die
Gesellschaft eben eint aber wir
versuchen der Ausstellung auch zu zeigen
dass sie auch ihre Schattenseiten hat
dass sie auch in der Sackgasse führen
kann wie die Vaterlandsliebe Führer
liebe liebe die auf Abwege geraten kann
es ist die Widersprüchlichkeit der Liebe
die sich hier hinter den roten Vorhängen
verbirgt da geht es um das langverbierte
Recht aufliebe genauso wie um Menschen
deren Liebe und Passion die Welt ein
wenig besser machen
Gerd Leipold kämpft seit 40 Jahren gegen
atomwaffenversuche im Meer Friedensliebe
es ist sicher nichts wo man sagen könnte
eine Liebe die ein blind macht im
Gegenteil man muss die Augen aufmachen
wenn man die Umwelt anschaut wenn man
das allerdings tut dann glaube ich kann
man nicht mehr wegsehen und kann man
auch nicht mehr aufhören damit nicht
wegsehen oft liegen Hass und Liebe nah
beieinander in Weissach im Tal zum
Beispiel nach einem Brandanschlag auf
eine geflüchteten Unterkunft setzten
sich viele Bürger gegen
Fremdenfeindlichkeit ein Handabdrücke
als Zeichen der Solidarität der
Nächstenliebe
auch Sonja protestiert hat ein
Brautkleid genäht aus
ablehnungsbescheiden weil sie nicht
heiraten darf den Mann den sie liebt und
mit dem sie ein Kind hat Mustafa aus
Gambia hat keine Geburtsurkunde und
damit keine offizielle Identität in
Deutschland
[Musik]
das wäre einfach viel schöner wenn wir
wenn wir einfach den Respekt bekämen dem
unsere Liebe gebührt
diese Ehe können die Behörden verhindern
ihre Liebe nicht die ist stärker
das definitiv mächtigste der Gefühle in
der Liebe ist nichts unmöglich die
Ausstellung läuft ab heute und dann noch
bis Mitte kommenden Jahres in Stuttgart
und das war es von uns für heute gegen 0
Uhr 25 gibt es unser heute journal
Update mit Christopher Wehrmann und vom
gesamten heute journal Team angenehmen
Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend ein kleines Tief zieht jetzt
von Frankreich heran für das weitere
Wettergeschehen sind aber das Hoch im
Osten und die Thies nordwestlich von uns
verantwortlich heute Nacht fällt viel
Regen innerhalb von 24 Stunden können im
Schwarzwald 30 bis 50 örtlich sogar 70
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen
kleinere Bäche können da über die Ufer
treten das wird eine sehr milde Nacht
mit Tiefsttemperaturen von 15 bis 10
Grad und morgen erwarten uns
Höchsttemperaturen in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen von 15 Grad 20 Grad
werden es zum Beispiel rund um Erfurt
der Regen der Nacht zieht morgen
ostwärts ab wird aber schnell abgelöst
von neuen Regen von Westen und Richtung
Niederlande und Belgien kann es am
Nachmittag auch mal Gewitter geben
zwischendurch werden sie morgen auch mal
die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen es wird
ein starker zum Teil sogar stürmischer
Wind aus südwestlichen Richtung und dann
wird die warmluftdüse angeschmissen denn
hier aus Richtung iberische Halbinsel
wird es zwischen dem hoch und den beiden
Thies noch mal richtig warm bei uns und
vielleicht kommt Anfang kommenden Woche
auch Saharastaub bei uns ab erstmal geht
es dann am Sonntag 25 Grad hier im
Südwesten und strahlenden Sonnenschein
viel Sonne scheint auch in
Schleswig-Holstein dort allerdings nur
bei 16 Grad und hier in der Mitte da
bleibt es am Sonntag eher bedeckt und
auch kühler und am Montag erwarten uns
dann ganz verbreitet Temperaturen über
20 Grad in Deutschland und in Sachsen
reicht's vielleicht sogar für 26 Grad
guten Abend